essentially a struggle problem it's an  open-ended thoughtful non routine  problem they're given a situation we go  outside and they pick a building they  collect certain data and using that data  as a group they have to figure out the  height of the building I may or may not  give them a couple of hints so now  Jeannette go all the way up to the  building to the very top be super  dramatic when you hit it double tap when  she's ready when you're ready tell us  and Brandon will double tap especially  in math it's so simple just be like this  is how you do it learn this now you're  not gonna remember that you're never  going to remember it how do we increase  like they're actually coming up with the  solution to things how do they  problem-solve sixty two point one  degrees  they want them to be able to like stand  on their own two feet and prove to  somebody else whether in school or in  life like why something is correct or  why something makes sense to them